[Music]
the internet has been obsessed with
spider-man no way home since it became
public knowledge rumblings of a
potential crossover with tom holland
andrew garfield and toby maguire's
incarnations of the titular wall crawler
have led fans to believe that this could
be one of the single most incredible
marvel cinematic universe installments
to date it remains to be seen if there's
any truth to such rumors at this point
but we do know that villains from all
three live-action spider-man franchises
are coming to the marvel cinematic
universe to give holland spider-man a
run for his money as revealed in the
first snowway home trailer doctor
stranger's attempt to use magic to
change peter parker's life for the
better has apparently gone terribly
wrong now spidey and the sorcerer
supreme have to contend with a myriad of
dangerous villains from across the
multiverse all while trying to send them
back to their respective timelines
electro and lizard represent the amazing
spider-man continuity with sandman dark
ark and green goblin carrying over from
director sam raimi's spider-man trilogy
the second trailer for spider-man no way
home gave fans a best look yet at all
five of these bad guys in action however
fans couldn't help but notice an odd
detail about the green goblin that has
laid the groundwork for an interesting
fan theory when green goblin first
appears in the most recent spider-man no
way home trailer he looks exactly the
same as he did in 2002's spider-man
wrapped in his jade armor complete with
his signature goblin mask he stands atop
his glider with a pumpkin bomb in hand
however norman osborne seems to try out
a brand new ensemble at some point in
the film goggles replace his helmet
additional armor sits on his arms and
legs purple accents cover his neck and
chest and he rides a redesigned glider
has the iconic spiderman foe gotten some
upgrades in the mcu or is something else
going on in no time at all twitter has
become entranced with this green goblin
situation so naturally theories have
already arisen
according to rotten tomatoes they're not
the same and this version of the
character will appear alongside the one
made famous in spider-man in trying to
sort out their true identity another
user posits that this could be a tweak
design for dame de haan's green goblin
from the amazing spider-man 2. meanwhile
another fan speculated that we may be
looking at mysterio using osborne's tech
to become a unique take on the hobgoblin
who are you
and where did you get all of those
weapons
it's all very compelling stuff and it
would make sense given the maximalistic
approach to the spider-man film cannon
that is being taken by no way home but
we should still brace ourselves for the
possibility that the solution is
significantly less thrilling
spider-man no way home has had a
particularly engaging roll out for fans
who love to analyze trailers and behind
the scenes speculation
from the early birds about the film's
ambitions to the ever still popular hunt
for definitive proof that toby maguire
and or andrew garfield will be returning
reading the proverbial tea leaves is
becoming as exciting as the movie itself
those who have been deep in the web of
no way home theories and alleged leaks
have seen some of those predictions come
true but perhaps that has made us all a
little too susceptible to seeing things
that aren't there we still can't say for
sure exactly what the answer to this
latest green goblin riddle is but we do
need to address the possibility that the
most obvious solution may also be a
disappointingly simple one in a piece
for slash film jeremy mathie proposes a
theory about the second green goblin
suit that is as logical as it is
unexciting as he lays it out if main
characters going through multiple
costume changes and a given superhero
movie is a time on a trope then it's not
the biggest stretch to imagine a villain
doing the exact same thing
so even if the blurry figure from the
trailer is indeed a different version of
the green goblin suit that doesn't
necessarily mean that it's a different
green goblin wearing it but thigh argues
that the second suit could merely be the
result of osborne sustaining enough
battle damage that he will end up
needing to rely on a backup more cobbled
together suit for future encounters
later in the film we'll all just have to
wait until spider-man no way home hits
theaters on december 17th to know for
sure
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite tv shows and movies are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]